my my
hello everybody we just hit four million
subscribers and I wish I could tell you
I prepared for you hey oh you wanted oh
oh they're little cookies I'm actually
back home in Cincinnati right now I
don't even have a DSLR my brother's
recording this on my iPhone
hi brother hello hello Tom of the
webcomic two kinds and come back here
Lucy where you going I can't let you go
run off you're not on a leash right now
so it's really cool to be back home I
got to see some of my friends and family
I'm gonna go hang out some people
tonight and uh it's just really good to
be back after being in LA for so long
not that I'm gonna be here permanently I
still need to go back to LA to take care
of business and all that stuff booty
over here we know boots we do Charlie I
know I'm gonna pay you some more anyway
I just wanted to say thank you guys so
much for supporting me through all of
this you know I I started out here with
my brother holding a camera if you
remember that Tom way back when I when I
first want to do sketch comedy in fact
the the stupid dragon ready to show over
there just a little outcome that's where
we bail me out red then some people saw
but was really stupid you looked we here
you'd week okay I know Charlie I can't
pet everyone at the same time but I just
wanted to say you know and spend a
really incredible journey to get from
nothing to four million subscribers and
I really do remember like every moment
of it especially the times that we had a
lot of fun because that me and Wade
filmed here for the first sketch comedy
we ever did and it was just really
stupid and not very well done but it
made us laugh and that's what's
important oh you gagging puppy this
Charlie by the way I don't know Charlie
and this is Lucy Oh Lucy's your big
Tweety anyway I just wanted to say thank
you guys so much for not only improving
my life but just making me have all
these opportunities Oh what you doing
you want to be let go I can't let you go
you're gonna go run off and do it off No
so I just wanted to say thank you guys
so much for getting me
amazing opportunities to have fun just
play around with wigs sweet bubble oh
look I know you want to run around when
you can you don't have a leash on right
now so just thanks again everybody so
much and we are doing a charity
livestream tomorrow I can't believe we
have 4 million subscribers 1 billion
video views and we're doing a charity
livestream all tomorrow it's just going
to be so much fun through your gigantic
tongue well all I get leaked we and
Ralia so I know this isn't very well
prepared and I know this is very fancy
and I wanted to do something special but
I've been so busy with all the all the
shoots and things with actual TV people
and very important things that I've been
doing you actually will see one of them
today it's really cool other thing I did
for Disney's new movie big hero 6 is
coming out today but just thank you guys
so much for this it really drives home
how important all this was to my life
now that I'm back and able to see my
friends
oh no miss you're so strong thank you
anyway so just thank you all so much for
watching and thank you all so much for
your support I'm gonna go because Lucy
wants to go running and I'm gonna need
the letter or else he's gonna really
start pulling and then I know she's
gonna pull me with her so Charlie I
can't be like you so just thank you
again everybody so much for 4 million
subscribers and as always we would hear
you in the next video goodbye goodbye
Charlie
bye